Oh my god.
Uggh they’re the weirdest animal ever!
Ahhh!
G’day.
I'm the resident nature nerd at ABC Science.
We’ve got plenty of deadly animals here
in Australia.
Now it’s time to look all around the world.
And today we're taking a deep dive into dangerous
aquatic animals.
From those with huge jaws…
Whoa! …to murderous molluscs.
That is sooo stupid!
I'm also going to speak to a ranger who’s
had close calls with deadly dinosaurs.
I'm going to review the best videos on the
internet to discover which of these five animals
are truly deadly.
Hippos.
The aquatic mammal that can't even swim.
How is it that a mostly vegetarian river giant
like that can be one of the most dangerous
animals in all of Africa?
Oh no.
Out of water in the daytime.
Roadworks.
Ooooh.
(swearing)
So one of the things that hippos do is use
their incredible jaw as like a rabbit trap.
They can open it up 150 degrees and then chomp
down like a death trap.
And that looks like it might have happened
in this case that the hippo actually charged
and chomped.
And that is a deadly combination.
They're good on land and they're pretty damn
good in water as well.
Whoa
Look at the waves it makes.
Oh.
What???
Shit that is huge.
It looks like a special effect.
Like a movie.
That is huge.
That is so cool.
And also in that slo-mo you see one of the
adaptations or behaviours that they do that
enables them to dive deep under the water.
When it comes up, you'll notice that its little
nostrils which have been closed under the
water open when they're up in the air.
I suppose like a blow hole from a whale.
Hippos are incredibly dangerous.
And hippos have been known to tip over kayaks
and things like that.
And it is thought that hippos are responsible
for something like 500 deaths every year in
Africa.
But most of those aren't from boat capsizing
but rather from people entering into a hippo's
territory from the water's edge.
That's a lot of people dying from hippos.
Look at this little beauty.
Ah look at those little ears.
Hippos are found in lakes and rivers all throughout
sub-saharan Africa.
From Sudan in the northeast all the way down
to the pointy bit, South Africa.
So they're called hippopotamus amphibious.
Amphibious means that they are both on land
and in water and hippopotamus comes from Greek
roots that actually means water horse.
Mean you can see why.
Look at that booty.
I actually think they could be called land
whales though.
Cause they're closest cousin on the taxonomic
tree is actually whales.
Oh look at how little the baby Ah.
Ah.
It's tiny.
I mean in saying that, they're born at about
45 kilograms.
So it’s not tiny.
So they'll stay in the water for like 16 hours
a day.
And they're nocturnal.
They'll come out at night and that's when
they do their grazing.
They are mostly vegetarian but eat something
like 45 kilograms of grass every day.
You can imagine how much hippo crap that is.
It’s a lot of hippo crap.
It's like a helicopter.
Doo doo doo doo doo.
How amazing are hippos?
There are so many different ecological benefits
from them moving between land and water and
one of the weirdest ones has to do with silicone
and poo.
Now silicone is a building block of life forms.
It’s the little structures that diatoms
build themselves out of.
Now diatoms are single cellular life forms
that form essentially the basis of the food
web.
So what the hippos do is eat kilograms of
grass every day.
One of the things that's in the grass is a
whole heap of silicone.
The hippos then acts like a bit of a silicone
conveyer belt, keep it in their tummy, get
all the way back into the water and crap it
out.
The silicone goes out into that watery ecosystem
and the diatoms are able to suck it all in
and reproduce.Because they eat so much grass
scientists thought that hippos were vegetarians.
If they are it turns out they're not very
strict.
Uh, oh.
We have a standoff here, an unusual scandal
for this part of the world.
We've got a crocodile and an impala.
This is fascinating.
The impala is going to make a run for it…
it’s going to be in trouble now.
This is going to give me a heart attack.
Oh this is unbelievable stuff.
Here comes a hippo or two.
Go impala!
There’s a hippo coming in.
I can’t believe what we’re seeing here.
This is normally seen in east Africa.
It’s all over.
Hippo leaping at the crocodile now.
It's precisely what we expected to happen,
wait if something came up two hours took a
leap there what's going on there i think they've
grabbed the crocodile.
Where did the second one come from?
Hippos don't like crocodiles.
It’s because crocodiles can prey on their
young.
When they see them in their territory, they're
likely to see them off the premises.
Oh look at how many there are.
Look at how many there are.
Wow.
Oooh.
Crocodile.
It ain't looking good for you mate.
Oooh…
Whaa, whaa.
You can see that these hippos are feeling
aggressive.
You're seeing some really big yawns that show
off their main weapon; those big teeth and
those huge jaws that can clamp down.
In fact the charge and chomp apparently ripped
in half a four metre crocodile once.
That's how powerful a hippo chomp is.
Goddamn big time.
So if you're kayaking you need to stay away
from hippo areas and if you know that you're
in a hippo area maybe bang the side of the
boat and make lots of noise so that they know
that you're coming along.
Don't sneak up on a hippo.
Octopus these molluscs are super freaky, but
how are they dangerous?
Oh god.
That looks to me to be like a blue-ringed
octopus, one of the most highly venomous animals
in the world.
And one of the ones that we do not have an
anti-venom for.
That is such a stupid, stupid thing to do.
Now bit of octopus anatomy for you right.
They've got a little beak and it's right in
the middle of their body underneath and that's
the bit that they inject venom with so it
needs to actually drop down onto its prey
to be able to kill it so these guys are literally
playing Russian roulette.
How they create that venom is actually in
their salivary glands they've got a little
bacteria in them and it creates tetradotoxin,
that is an incredibly strong chemical that
is a neurotoxin.
So the first thing that's going to happen
is you're going to start to feel like your
arms and legs are a bit numb or tingly, your
speech will become impaired, you might vomit
then you'll become paralyzed and won't be
able to move, you'll still be fully conscious
but you'll likely die from lack of oxygen.
It's not a pleasant process to go through
and if you do see a blue-ringed octopus, take
a photo and don't touch it
Look at these spots whoa.
So this is a day octopus right and they're
soft-bodied it means that they're really very
vulnerable to attack so they use camouflage.
They can change their colors using chromatophores
and they can also change the texture using
these little lumps that they can sort of bring
up and it means that see how the bottom of
the ocean in this part is sort of lumpy and
algae it can make itself look like it's got
the lumps.
Look at that, that is so cool.
I do believe that this octopus has probably
been disturbed by this diver and that's why
it's doing such visualization and that's a
great view of the texture that it can change
make itself look like it's a completely different
object
What a performance.
It's gonna be cool.
You see that slot.
No way you can't get it.
You are wrong my friend
Now octopuses can be very small or very large
but the important thing is they don't feel
restricted by their size.
He can go through anything that his beak fit
through.
The giant pacific octopus is giant.
It's the biggest octopus that there is.
A lot of them grow to about five meters which
is sort of terrifying.
If you watch he's gonna go right through there.
Octopuses aren't shapeshifters, they're invertebrates
and that means they don't have an internal
skeleton they've got that little bony beak
and they've got a bit of cartilage that protects
their brain but apart from that it's malleable.
That means that they can fit through tiny
holes they can spread out wide like a parachute
and they can do all sorts of things... it's
frankly i'm a bit jealous
The octopus brain is different than the human
brain.
They have what's called decentralized intelligence
it means that there's a core of brain.
It's like a donut.
It's in the bell part of their body.
All the way out their arms they have neurons
which is sort of crazy to think about and
it means that if an arm gets chopped off it'll
actually continue to do the action that it
was meant to be doing even though it's disembodied
from the main part of the octopus' intelligence.
There's his nose.
He's just all the way through it now except
for...
Yeah oh dear.
You're not going to get it off either.
Cause if you remove one arm it’s got like
seven other arms.
There are documented cases of octopus attack
but the thing is almost all of them have a
backstory right, where the octopus was provoked
in some way.
Divers who regularly dive say that one of
the most important things to do is to protect
your air source.
It must be like trying to fight angry jelly.
If it wanted to it could potentially really
injure this bloke.
Is he saying take a photo?
Hello I'm here from the future to warn you
that the next clip made me make an eek face.
It's a bit disturbing so keep that in mind.
Look at those suckers.
I think I remember seeing this at the time.
It's filmed overseas and I think that this
girl was making a series about eating live
seafood which is common in some cultures around
the world but in the case of octopuses it's
probably not a good idea.
Look at it pulling her eye.
So what is amazing about seeing this octopus
attack this vlogger's face is that you can
actually see how nimble each individual sucker
is.
They can really actually rotate and move.
They're incredibly strong and you can get
octo-hickeys from them so I wouldn't be surprised
if the day after she was actually bruised.
She did get a cut.
Quite frankly she got off lightly.
It's also really dangerous to eat octopus
arms that are freshly taken from the octopus
because they've got that decentralized nervous
system it means that they keep wriggling for
quite some time, sometimes in excess of 15
minutes, and there have been cases of people
eating fresh octopus arms and actually choking
because as they go down the suckers suck onto
the inside of their throat.
So let that be a lesson.
Most octopuses are actually really shy and
retiring.
They like to hide away and avoid confrontation
so to avoid getting an octopus hug from eight
very strong neuron filled sucker-lined arms
the best thing to do is give them space, space
that they can go about their octopussy business
and we can admire them from afar because there's
so much to admire.
We've got even better videos to come so stay
tuned.
We usually think of sea lions as harmless
and playful and like doggos of the sea, so
why are they getting reputation for being
so aggressive?
Hey, he's fighting my kayak.
What are you doing?
One of the ways you can tell this is a sea
lion and not a seal is because it's got little
external ear bits.
Seals have holes sea lions have little external
ears.
He wants my fish.
Yes he does want your fish.
Don't bite me.
Your fishy's here.
That is a risk.
He knew it was coming.
He knew he was doing the wrong thing.
This is often how interactions with wild animals
go.
You see it clearly had got fish off fishermen
before because it just kept on harassing them
until it got what it wanted and that's why
feeding animals is bad.
It habituates them to human contact and then
that can impact negatively on the humans and
also on the animals but yeah what a pretty
little thing.
"Hi" look at the little whiskies.
It still disappears in that water though doesn't
it?
That's definitely a male because it's got
that big forehead, quite flat.
It's probably a California sea lion.
Feeding it.
Why would you do that?
It is so dangerous.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Crikey that's why you don't feed animals.
It habituates them to being around you and
expecting food.
Every animal is different and you never know
how one is going to react.
There were so many signs - circling back around,
locked eyes, it started to lift itself out
of the water before it even lunged.
Like i mean so many signs.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Though this was a pretty aggressive sort of
attack I don't think there's many fatalities
from sea lion attacks at least not that I've
heard of yet.
Oh that's so dangerous because these air pipes
are like right there.
Getting the shot though.
Oh those teeth.
Really strong teeth and as they age they often
become black because of bacteria in the mouth.
It's probably a young seal.
Maybe it's exploring the texture of the wetsuit.
Maybe it's just being naughty.
That's terrifying.
That charging blowing bubbles barking, that's
the sort of thing that says from the sea lion,
"get the hell out of here".
So the sea lion, they're generally more curious
than they are aggressive but they can deliver
a nip and that can be bad.
On top of that that can have a really massive
infection so it's best to keep your distance.
After all it's in the name 'lion'.
Sea lion.
You don't go close to it.
For a creature that's been around for 200
million years it's actually really surprising
how widespread crocodile species.
They are they're found in 26 countries in
Africa alone and that species is named after
that huge river, the Nile.
Oh my god.
When a croc is lucky enough to actually capture
its prey item the've got something like 65
teeth.
It's not necessarily the teeth that you've
got to be worried about, it's the bite force.
(This is incredibly rare to see.
There's another crocodile coming in now.)
The most of any animal in the world that they've
been able to measure so far.
Coming around, coming around.
Big one in front.
Around the world there's an estimated 1,000
people that die every year from crocodile
attacks.
It's definitely more fatal than sharks.
Now we're on to the sunshine state of the
US, Florida.
Pete, you're too close to him.
It's really asking for trouble isn't it, when
you take out a camera when you're in a canoe?
You just know it's going to end poorly.
Oh god Pete your pedals are too close to that
one.
Sorry.
These are really cool reptiles.
Their whole structure around their face is
built so that they can pretend to be a stick.
It's got pretty good hearing so when he lets
out these little screams the crocs probably
heard it.They've got little holes with flaps
that are behind their eyes and actually their
ear canals are really interesting.
They sort of don't have two separate ears
like we do but rather a tube that goes all
the way through their head which is... which
is sort of cool but yeah.
They can hear pretty well.
The crocs would have known that they were
there for sure.
Mudskipper.
Why is it that they always stop?
There's never any closure on these things.
Ah that seemed to be a little croc and it
looks like it was that ambush behavior.
Like it just popped up out of nowhere.
Probably would go for the mudskipper but it
might have been attracted by the movement
of the tourists so that is something to think
about.
Just wandering along beside a waterway is
a dangerous thing to do.
Little doggo there's a big croc there mate.
Woah!
She's gonna thong it.
Yeah it backed off.
Bloody worked!
That is the most Australian thing I have seen.
Not in the recommended playbook when it comes
to dealing with crocodiles.
So the recommended advice if you see crocs
or you're in crop territory is to spend as
little time as possible at the water's edge
and also to move about your position at the
edge of the water so instead of going every
day at the same time to get water from the
river you want to move up and down the bank
so you're not predictable for the crocodile.
For some people including indigenous Australians
crocodile attack is a daily risk.
I spoke to ranger Greg Wilson who has regular
run-ins with crocs.
You know they call Australia, the lucky country
but I don't think that's what they were talking
about.
It's no surprise crocodiles are deadly but
their attacks are pretty rare and they're
mostly preventable.
Remember if you're near the water, your safety
is your responsibility.
Not the crocs'.
Yep it's the biggest scariest fish in the
ocean, the great white shark.
Sharks.
What do we got here?
A spear fisherman in South Africa okay.
That means there's potentially blood in the
water if you've been lucky enough to get a
fish.
Okay I thought the rock was a shark then.
This is why I'm not a diver.
Woaha hi.
Hi.
It's like a charge that that shark just did,
came out of nowhere, turned away at the last
minute.
That was saying, "move out of my territory".
So it looks like it's actually a small shark.
There's a chance that it might be just as
scared of the diver.
They both just like scared each other as they
came around the corner of the rock and you
know it was just a misunderstanding.
Incredible but he did do the right thing.
He got out of there.
All right, here we are in Urunga in New South
Wales.
It's chasing me.
Wow.
Wow oh that went close.
(Hey Dave.
Come here please.)
Yeah you come over here into the dead danger
zone.
(Holy that's a big white.
He's very interested in me.).
It's the little leg pumps.
It's like worst predator in the world...
I can hear him coming like I'm paddling.
I can hear him thumping away behind me.
To me this behavior isn't attacking.
If it wanted to attack him and kill him it
probably would have done so.
It just seems more curious.
Splashing the water with your paddle probably
isn't the best thing to do because what it
says to the shark is that perhaps there's
something that's in a little bit of distress
that's quite interesting there in the water.
So yeah that's probably not the recommended
thing to do.
In fact you probably want to be as uninteresting
as possible.
But if a shark does attack you it is a very
good idea to use the paddle to boop it on
the nose.
It's got quite sensitive little schnoz and
on top of that you can go for the eyes as
well.
Caveat on that, very important not to boop
a shark that's just saying hello and being
curious.
You don't want to escalate things with the
shark just wants to check you out rather than
attack you.
Wow look at that.
You see that the shark is just going for the
cage.
That is such a good shot.
The shark teeth are amazing.
They're serrated and you can see that they
point backwards into the shark's mouth it's
essentially a huge set of fish hooks that
go into the flesh and it means that even if
you tried you're not going to get away, you're
just going to push yourself deeper into these
razor-sharp serrated teeth.
So if a great white shark wants to get you
yeah it's going to get you.
We got a big great white out there.
We recommend get out asap.
There's a big great white shark out there.
Australia records the highest number of shark
fatalities in the world.
But there are some things that we can do to
make sure we get a warning before the sharks
get too close.
(Yeah I'm on it bro.)
One of them is drones that are used to basically
spot the shark and give warning to people
to get out of the water.
(No don't go out.
There's a big great white out there.)
It's actually so beautiful and calming to
watch it and that's what 99% of the time our
interactions with these animals are.
Worldwide about four people die every year
from shark attack but every single year a
hundred million sharks and rays are removed
from the world's ocean by commercial fishing.
The disparity is just amazing.
These aren't really a risk to our wellbeing,
in fact they aid our well-being.
(He's over there, yeah.)
When you take out these top-order predators
the fish that normally would be kept into
control by great white sharks might proliferate.
They eat all of the plants, the seagrass meadows.
These ecosystems are incredibly important
in combating climate change because they sink
carbon so what we must do is include in conservation
planning these top-order predators because
their part along with every other organism
below them is critical to our future survival.
Oh yeah.
Sharks are absolutely deadly in all senses
of the word but when it comes to avoiding
a bite really it's all about perspective and
prevention.
You're much more likely to die of drowning
than you are of a shark bite and if the shark
bite is truly a fear of yours then the answer
is not going in the water.
So there you have it, some of the world's
most dangerous aquatic animals.
Sure they can be scary but there's plenty
to be impressed by, from the highly evolved
apex predators with their incredibly sharp
senses to the giant mammals whose poo breathes
life into whole ecosystems and then there's
the ones that have three hearts blue blood
and neurons in their arms.
See you next time.
Thanks for watching and if you like this video
why don't you click around because on ABC
Science we've got heaps of videos that are
just like this.
In fact we upload them every single week so
it's worth hitting subscribe and I'll see
you here next time.